hey what is going on you sexy people
this episode is brought to you by gold
thread now if you haven't heard of gold
thread before gold thread is an outlet
of filmmakers and reporters that
basically do anything that have to deal
with Chinese travel food and culture and
it's dope but check this out
if you go to the link in the description
box below you click that and subscribe
to their channel through that link you
can win a MacBook Air they're giving
away not just one but three MacBook Airs
all you got to do click that link and
from that link subscribe to them and
check it out you can win a MacBook Air
Beibei so go ahead and do that and if
you have the time check out their
channel they have some dope content I've
actually worked with them before and you
could check that out we basically went
to a situation we a search one food and
we talked about Chinese culture and
things and it was dope so give that a go
and win a free MacBook Air babe a in a 5
4 3 2 1
surprise [ __ ] welcome to another
episode of a genius brain I am one of
your hosts Jody Sakawa and I'm David so
and today we have some special talks but
before I get into that I want to talk
about something even more important have
you ever kicked anybody in the middle of
your sleep no [ __ ] kick the [ __ ] out
of my dog this morning oh really yeah
I had this dream like a [ __ ] man
I felt so God like [ __ ] side kicked
the [ __ ] out of my dog so like um in my
dream me and Jes it was like
post-apocalyptic kind of world we were
in a garage and then I jumped on top of
a car to like to get to the second level
like I had to grab like like the that
stairs were broken so I had to like jump
on a car from a car I did like jump on
like do some parkour [ __ ] and she
grabbed on my leg and then she started
talking some [ __ ] and I'm all like let
go huh and then she's like she's like
she's like why don't you tell me that
you had ration
in your pocket and I'm like [ __ ] I was
gonna share that [ __ ] with you and then
and she kept tugging on my leg and I was
like I can't get to the other side like
and she's like well I can't jump that
thing and I'm like well let me go and
I'll you know and I'll lift you up right
and then I didn't I kicked I kicked down
like you know when someone thought yeah
yeah yeah I'm just like you're just
trying to kick down like that and I went
boom and I woke up and both of my duck
my dog where hey and she jumped off the
bed and both of my dogs exploded she
didn't wake up though and both of my
dogs jumped off and I was like I'm so
[ __ ] sorry dude check this [ __ ] out
of him
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] Muriel this
morning you know I was actually late
today so I was gonna leave on time but
turns out Muriel the moment she wakes up
she goes I had a terrible dream last
night I'm like mmm about what she was
about you I'm like was she mad at you so
was it one of those dreams yeah so she
woke up mad at me not from what I've
done in real life but what I hid in the
dream
and she was so upset and I was like yeah
what the [ __ ] it was the second time you
got mad at me about having a dream about
me dude and so her dream was it I went
into her look it's not even even in the
dream it's not a big deal in the her
dream I went into her bathroom yeah I
think a huge [ __ ] [ __ ] and I messed
it up and I said to her she goes it's
not a big deal and from that she was
screaming at me in the dream saying it
is a big deal and I pushed [ __ ] all over
toilet she's like if you're not gonna
clean it up I'm gonna leave you and I
was like whatever go ahead yeah I was a
good [ __ ] like and she got mad at me
this morning because I said well it's
naughty even if it's in the dream it's
not a big deal even in the dream oh no
even more for sure why would you say
you're telling me that in your dream you
were gonna leave me because I left a
[ __ ] street mark in your toilet
that's all it takes
what the [ __ ] man she acts like you
cheated on her yeah dude oh man
jess was mad at me because she she had a
dream that I fell in love with this
Indian woman what the [ __ ] I know right
like it's it's just bizarre she was like
yeah she was
you were just badly
love with his Indian girl and then and
then like you cheated on me with her and
I'm like well first of all like what
Indian girls are pretty yeah I just
don't know many Indians yeah so I don't
know where did I find her yeah like
maybe I was at an Indian restaurant they
have regular job I thought about it too
like if I had a because I've had dreams
about other women before yeah but in the
dream I'm not with Muriel I'm single
yeah it's like you're back in time or so
yeah like it's a different life cause I
don't think I should feel guilty about
that because in the dream itself I'm by
myself like she doesn't exist so that's
not really cheating you know what I
think
dreams are it's when you are in a
different dimension like you know how do
you know the parallel world yeah yeah so
but like you're there you're visiting
there are you know I do when I when I
thought about that [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
crazy because I have I just talked about
this on a previous podcast to where I
can't along all these weird dreams that
I've had so when she had that dream I
had a [ __ ] weird dream where it was
about a girl and I don't remember who
the girl is but when I essentially like
I I walked up this winding staircase
into like one of those empty type of
warehouses but when I walked up the
winding staircase and I got into this
room it was kind of it looked like one
of those reformed LA laughs OH
and in those la lost like all the all
the stuff is like super modern and then
I lay on this this.l couch and on the L
couch I'm laying down and I looked to my
left and there's a girl next to me and
then she's like very friendly with me
and she kind of seemed like somebody I
knew but it's one of those things that I
feel like it's probably somebody that I
saw in passing yeah and it's just
subconscious remembered remembered it so
I'm looking at this asian girl he was
very pretty and she looks over at me and
then we're just talking and whatever and
it all said she leans over and she just
kisses me and I'm like the [ __ ] yeah
this is kind of weird but you know I'm
not with Marilyn yeah like I'm just a
single dude traveling around LA yeah and
then she starts kissing me and then she
starts calling up next to me and I'm
like cuddling with her and then next
thing you know the dream flips and then
we're in that LA loft and then I'm
taking photos of her I'm a photographer
yeah I'm taking photos of her and then
as after I take photos of her I go to my
computer to look at the photos and every
photo that I have of her she doesn't
have a face
oh yes Larry yeah and I'm looking
through the fussin were the [ __ ] what
what the [ __ ] is our for two-face go yes
I'm looking through all the photos and
her face is blinking it's like hush this
world and smeared like like an oil
painting I think that uh that that face
filter yeah snapchat we're [ __ ] warps
it yes I was like looking at her photos
was like I can't find her face and I
look up and she has no face at all and
then I wake up its ex lender man and
[ __ ] dude it was [ __ ] creepy and
that's why I was dreaming about it she
was over dreaming that I [ __ ] in her
toilet
oh yeah that's her nightmare yeah you
lived the caucus Street [ __ ] toilet I
had a real nightmare she did it down she
said to her that's a nightmare I hurt
her nightmares me [ __ ] leaving Dookie
and her nightmare can come true yeah I
think that's what got her because it
felt too real because I did leave a
streak stain in her toilet once and she
got mad but then I cleaned it out there
I got I got the why would you break up
with me before that's not that's the
part I didn't get like why break up with
me because of it not a big deal she's in
the dream I said I'm leaving and you
were okay with it I was like that sounds
pretty real
yeah if you started screaming at me
because I left the streak stain in your
toilet I definitely leave cracks she's
[ __ ] funny dude that's dough she's
such a weirdo dude okay the topic of
today oh yeah that's right the topic of
today is mr. Jesse small a you know like
I didn't even look into the original
Jesse Smollett thing until recently just
because well I heard enough about it
from other people and then a couple of
like just looking through some articles
yeah and so the premise of it is that he
prior to him being caught for this he
did a setup where he said where was he
at what what state well what's it say
Cosmo cago he was a Chicago and he said
that a couple of dudes and Magga hats
came up to him they threw some kind of
chemical on him put a noose on his head
and said a bunch of like racial and smog
a country or some [ __ ] like that which
already off the bat sounds really
suspicious
yeah it sounds really suspicious like it
sounds like out of a movie yeah like
like they like this is like 1970 and
they beat up a black guy and
like this is our time yeah it's like cuz
its first of all it's chic ah go so I
mean if this was like Indiana or maybe
the border of Illinois I get it but like
I don't know yeah you know um who
actually was skeptical about it first
before I before it was revealed that
something happened [ __ ] Tim Tim was
like really and Tim was like yo this he
goes like I want to be for this guy but
everything sounds too convenient like it
sounds weird you know I mean and so Tim
always had like a weird feeling about it
yeah next thing you know there's my kids
like I [ __ ] told you yeah that's a
good detective
yeah he just had like a weird gut
feeling about yeah I think my we're
gonna eat said he was going to a subway
at midnight she's no button no black
people eat subway like that if he's a
cop I've never seen a single black
person at midnight eat a subway yeah
that's a white truck traffic if it was a
white truck driver going to subway in a
midden middle of the night it's like all
right stuff I don't think so that's true
if I was like an Asian guy going to
Subway nah fall restaurant yeah hot
[ __ ] Asian Bistro on a Hong Kong cafe
Denny's if they're desperate
yeah but they they they found out
through they did the the police
department did investigative work and
things just weren't adding up Yeah right
so they well he he he also said like he
got this letter oh that's right the
letter a letter that was like like out
of the movies like a like a serial
killer magazine cut out like you know I
forgot what it said and then they had
some kind of powder which was like a
crushed up Tylenol so you know it was
like anthrax threat whatever it's like
somebody who gets caught in a lie you
just keep lying even more I am a victim
of his yeah it's like because okay well
I did this so maybe I should make a fake
letter cut out letters just like in Val
Kilmer and that [ __ ] bad Batman movie
yeah it's like the [ __ ] is this guy
doing dude does it make any sense and
why is he a target like like our white
supremacists watching [ __ ] Empire and
they're like we're getting that
[ __ ] right there you're like
like I would
assume that a black politician or
[ __ ] I don't know al Sharpton or you
know one of those guys the black rights
you know
yeah like leaders or something is he
like a huge voice and representation for
the black community this does he's is he
like outspoken about that [ __ ] so why
don't he be singled out out of everybody
yeah that was kind of weird yeah because
I would I would probably trust like a
just random black dude off the street
more than like a uh uh a guy that's like
in a black he's like super content yeah
you know first of all he's like super
clean cut you know what I mean like he
doesn't he's like super clean-cut he's
light-skinned like yeah I think he would
be he wouldn't beat the prime suspect
for something like that yeah you know I
don't know he just seems a long weird I
just think they wouldn't know who he is
yeah cuz I didn't know who he was
yeah III think Empire is a relatively
big show but I I think in our group of
friends to and even even like my black
friends like big know of Empire but they
didn't know so it's not just the urban
not maybe it's a southern like mono like
maybe just in LA it's not that big so
maybe yeah I don't know yeah cuz I just
I didn't know anything about the dude
until like it all this all came out yeah
like who the [ __ ] is Jesse Smollett I
didn't know yeah it's not it's not
relevant to me but it's pretty nuts how
everything kind of played out yeah
because whenever as racial [ __ ] does go
down like that though you you go all
again yeah like you don't you don't
doubt it you don't doubt that it's not
real yeah like for me I don't I I
believe that it was happening I was like
aw poor guy yeah well he kind of played
it too big that's like me saying like
okay well last night I went to a Burger
King and two white people we maggot hats
picked me up by my ankles and they they
Japanese bound my feet and told me to
walk with the teacup in my head they
forced me to [ __ ] eat my own dog you
know like it's pretty extreme right like
okay like he got something out of a
history book and I did that and I mean
there is some real racism out there you
know some real [ __ ] like um you know I
was listening to this one podcast by
ciggy Jackson because I was like
listening to the whole Michael Jackson
thing
and right here in California they were
one of the first black families to move
into Encino oh yeah and then they you
know had people tell them like what are
you doing here in word like and then
yell at them and be nasty and then like
all of their white neighbors that were
cool they got called like n-word lovers
stuff like that and uh what wound up
happening was once they found out they
were the Jackson family the Jackson 5
and related to all of them that then
they were like oh that's cool like hey
can I get it can I get a ticket to your
uncle's concert and like everyone was
fine yeah and then but this was I don't
know this was a long time ago like you
know yeah it's like you know I don't
know when but it's like it's not recent
you know but when they were I think well
he was trying to say is like even in
California where you think it's a
liberal accepting inclusive state like
it wasn't that way not too long ago
there was an area near Sacramento called
El Dorado Hills yeah and I found it out
out about the Stewart friend and I guess
like he had a friend who was trying to
buy a house out there but when he was
buying the house one of the property he
looked at he looked through the contract
or whatever well before he bought it and
there was a clause still in El Dorado
Hills where it said that people of color
couldn't move into El Dorado Hills oh
did you know the suburbs was an actual
thing to get it's like for white flight
out of the city oh really yeah because
minorities and black people's well
mainly they couldn't own cars so when
they started moving into the cities to
get coke to be closer to their jobs and
stuff like that you know why people
didn't like that mainly because of the
difference in culture and way of life
right so they wanted like an area that
was gated and stuff so a lot of suburbs
and gated communities was a way for them
to have their own lifestyle but then
they could commute to work to the city I
was watching this whole [ __ ] about and I
was like dang I didn't know the history
of it was that because I remember like
so Gardena California
is is a highly per now it's a lot of
black and Mexicans but back in the days
to be a lot of Japanese farmers yeah and
they told me the history of it was back
then the South Bay a lot of that area
was farmland so now it's all covered in
suburb but when I say back then I'm only
talking about 1950 oh [ __ ] that's not
long ago cuz my friends grandpa owned
land there and all that and he was
telling me about the history and he was
like well there were things called um I
forgot the name but it's like it's this
rule right it is called a something town
but there's this rule that like when
when the sun goes down it's like sunset
then all the black people have to go so
during the daytime black people can come
and they can shop and they can work
there and they can do whatever but then
when it when it turns like oh it's but
it's curfew or whatever the sun you know
it's sunset and then they have to go
back to their neighborhoods and stuff
like that but back i think back then
that you know like the the content and
all the areas that are like the hood
like before there weren't that many
black people it was like you know white
people whatever yeah and then all of the
Gardena area was farms and in torrance
the neighboring city in the beach cities
they wouldn't rent to non-whites so yeah
well I mean even even Asians you know
like cuz cuz back then Japanese people
were like what poor farmers right but
until the 80s that's when like what
we're witnessing today with rich Chinese
mainlanders coming in and buying up all
the real estate that was Japanese people
in the 80s and 90s oh with Toyota hot
like all of these big companies starting
to move into America so they would send
all their like executives out to the
California they would just buy up all
the property and then that South Bay
area started to have more affluent
Japanese people palos verdes and all
that stuff but yet I mean that's after
the civil rights and after they they had
those laws of like you can't do the rent
thing yeah you can't do rent based off
of uh if you're not white or what
Yeah right yeah but um it's very recent
like a lot of a lot of people told me
these stories that are still alive today
and and you know like wow we have a
family friend who grew up in the Midwest
and he had it even worse because during
elementary school like you know right
after world war ii or during or whatever
they would have full-grown adults chuck
like rocks at them as their kids and
they would they would have to they would
have to sprint home as soon as the bell
rang day would have to run all the way
home because like whoever saw him on the
street like these you know guys would
just start chucking rocks adults kids
everybody yeah yeah stupid Jack get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah and then so what
his dad did was like he was like well
work you know they're poor farmers out
there they're like we don't we can't
just get up and move you know so his dad
bought them two helmets like who
straight up like what the [ __ ]
so they're so at least like when they go
home you know they won't have their head
damaged yeah so every day after school
him and his little brother got together
they put their helmets on and they
[ __ ] booked it every day they ran
home yeah that's [ __ ] crazy dude yeah
and then like all of their Asian friends
would come to school with a tag a big
tag on their shirt that says I am NOT
Japanese I'm Chinese yeah because they
will get [ __ ] up cuz you know Asians
look the same so they don't know yeah
they're just like hey I'm Chinese I'm
Japanese I'm not one of the enemies oh
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] crazy yeah you
know I didn't realize to like it's not
that it's only like one generation back
- yeah I've experienced this stuff so
it's still relatively new
maybe it's because like a lot of people
didn't talk to me about it growing up
and I'm Korean they're new immigrants
Yeah right so I mean you guys did go
through whatever but you don't have
great I mean your grandpa and here you
have more stories of like Korean War
Korea yeah yeah because I have Japanese
American relatives yeah tell me about
like what happened and all that [ __ ] cuz
I only have like one uncle that talks
about how who talked about how he so he
used to go to this school called El Crow
hi which is still around there till this
day but when he went to Oak Grove I he
said like people you said all that's
mother [ __ ] he said that people would
come come and park the horses there
that's all oh yeah he's all bike but you
know a sacrament was a farm town so I
see how that wasn't that it's not that
comment like you did your high school
have a farming like we had a we had our
Aggie club around we had that too cuz
Gardena used to be a farm town oh yeah
see I had all that stuff so he's talking
about how back in today where he he was
like the only Asian kid that was in the
football team in Oak Grove wasn't big
he's pretty violent dude this guy's a
violent [ __ ] but he's still so
he has old man strength but this guy
beats my ass ever you met him the
[ __ ] talkative do member ah yeah yeah
yeah he told us the story he'll say yell
back in my day I was the only Asian guy
and Elk Grove High he goes these
[ __ ] they used to call me
chenkin pull back by their eyes and make
fun of me you know what I would do I
bring my nunchucks and I beat the [ __ ]
dude these old guys are no joke - yes
what it was when he was fighting to me
like I was the only Asian guy in that
school and yeah everybody tried to Punk
me so he developed a relationship or a
reputation of just being a violent
[ __ ] well you had to be it was
survival yeah right because and that's
how a lot of these Asian gangs started
because of that bullying mentality
yeah and it's and that's how a lot of
these gangs start because they people
eventually get tired of being picked on
and so there's always strength in
numbers
well even some Asian gangs start because
Asian Americans pick on them like watch
it yeah like a big one was like after
the Vietnam War the Vietnamese refugees
yeah they you know they were there like
all the Asian Americans were picking on
the fobs I said they they got together
and they made Asian Boyz yeah that's so
crazy because like I remember like some
of these dudes told me stories of like
when when their older brothers who were
you know they used to be gay the
reformed now they had on a wife they had
kids but they were talking about stories
of like they would tell us you know back
in our days like we had to do it or we
would just get bullied all the [ __ ]
time yeah like it wasn't even one of
those things where we were trying to be
tough
it says we came from a war-torn country
like I saw my uncle
my cousin's everybody getting killed so
if you come up to me and you're talking
about you gonna beat me up I'm a [ __ ]
cut your head off
it's like oh yeah I mean even even with
white folks - yeah like I think it was
just tougher yeah cuz I was talking to
Jess's uncle he's like 89 well he just
passed yeah but um he was telling me
when he was in high school like if he
had beef with somebody and the teachers
knew it his dad was a teacher
they let him just they're like hey you
two you end this right now go and then
like oh let him Duke it out that's a
Hawaiian [ __ ] yeah he's like they don't
do that these days anymore so you know
maybe it's it's just back then everybody
was tough like everybody was crazy yeah
everyone was they just you know or maybe
more barbaric is the word yeah they
don't think words were an option is just
evil but what he said it there was a lot
of honor to like they just they do watch
it out man and they're like okay okay no
more you know that make sense to me
because I saw that in Hawaii a lot yeah
the first time I ever went to Hawaii I
saw I was at a bar with you know with
salmon them yeah and there's just dude
you're saying well so you want you want
beef brah you want beef you know this
[ __ ] [ __ ] in Hawaii and it's out it
still sounds nice you know you want beef
bras like em with sube I was like that's
why this muffins work in the kitchen
what's going on but you know beef just
means that you want to fight you got
prom with me but they went on to the
parking lot
they [ __ ] duked it out they were just
swinging on each other one dude got
[ __ ] knockdown they pulled him off
he's like what's up didn't really do
much after that they got up they [ __ ]
shook hands they do bottom a beer and
they moved on and that's how it should
be I was like wow that's you can't just
like talk [ __ ] to people like yes if
you're gonna say some [ __ ] you got to
back it up and they did at least try to
back it up yeah ass beat you know but
yeah they they kind of squashed it and
move on and this was like seven or eight
years ago and I heard it still you know
they had that still that mutual respect
where it's just like it's their culture
yeah I mean I don't know if it still
goes on like that but I feel like it
depends on where you're living in who
you're around a bunch of moksa [ __ ] yeah
it just Dookie yeah yeah I thought that
was wild because I haven't seen that in
a long time
it's been a while since I seen something
like that but we're also away from that
yeah and we're like older we don't go
out at night oh yeah yeah whenever I go
out at night I'm reminded of like I'll
get nervous I don't go out it because of
these drunk [ __ ] that always want to
fight
well that's very prevalent man when I
had a cousin that came here to LA and
then she wanted to she's super young so
she wanted to go out eat drink and go to
these clubs I didn't go to the club but
I a couple my other cousins went with
her but I left yeah because like the
moment you walk in that line there's
already a bunch of dudes looking at you
it's weird it's like what the [ __ ] are
you looking at you know I mean but
they're just tough guys they're sizing
you up yeah sizing me up what the [ __ ]
dude but they're just looking at you
like like almost as if you're looking at
the girl that they're with yeah he's
looking at your [ __ ] ugly ass girl
dude like they're like a six like in in
their little town she's like the hottest
thing they've ever said so they have to
keep her protected and [ __ ] dude there
was this a joint out in Sacramento
called Polaris so if you're from
Sacramento about Pilar she's like an 18
and up lounge but it's technically a
club but there was always these like
Asian thugs there I had a friend who
[ __ ] got into a brawl is side polari
and this fool came out and he had like
some blood on his hand uh-oh yeah what
the [ __ ] him is that [ __ ] stabbed
this [ __ ] up
oh so you stabbed somebody it's full he
stabbed somebody fingernail clipper you
know the look he's bragging about mask
you disgusting [ __ ] full probably has
an infection now you disgusting bastard
he has toenail grease all over his body
oh dude that place was so [ __ ] ghetto
dude that is I don't know but that's the
type of environment that's I don't know
what it is but I think when you just
smash a bunch of jizz young people which
is high testosterone and alcohol and no
purpose yeah there's there's just dumb
yeah I've never liked clubs though me
neither well I did cuz I like seeing
girls dressed up I think I like dancing
I like dancing I only went to clubs I
think that's like it was a huge peer
pressure thing for me also because my
dad wanted to go Club and they wanted to
go drinking in advance yeah once you
drink like it's cool but you know for me
like after a while I think I only
probably maybe and
for about like a year or two yeah after
that I was already like I just know you
know what it was it's cuz I went with
the people that fought that's why well
cuz they're over there fighting
sometimes I get in whatever um but I
don't feel like the tension only
medicine the worst was when you go in
and then you have to leave and you spent
like 30 minutes driving yeah you're like
I just stepped foot in this [ __ ]
man all right I'm just talking to this
girl what the [ __ ] man it is not their
fight and it got bad man it got to the
point where like they got to crazy and
they would it was just senseless
violence and then they weren't just
throwing hands anymore they were like
shooting and fight we used to go to
clubs and like we did you when you got
to go to clubs out here in LA did you
have to dress up like you had to wear a
collared shirt oh well you have to
because there's dress code now I enjoy
leisurely do you don't have to wear a
college it was back then they knew
everything was gang-related so they were
trying people to not like they didn't
want people to wear their colors they
didn't want people to like you know it
was like no dress shirt yeah no dress
shoes you can't even come in and they
wanted that upscale look even though
like then what early 2000s it still
looked cheap everything was swapped me
[ __ ] you know
she was I guess it was kind of fun back
in the day but I you see you didn't even
drink my juice to drink a lot I didn't
drink but I did drugs yeah yeah way
worse that I drink a lot dude well cuz I
can't drink I don't enjoy it yeah yeah
man I had this one friend he's
completely sober right he recently
started drinking in his late 20s but he
wanted to go to clubs just to fight I
was like come on dude you could join a
gym or yeah every time you go to the
club I'm like so you want to pay $20 so
you can start fighting somebody inside
of a club you [ __ ] crazy ass do I
it's so funny because I don't I don't
think I think that if I grew up with
better people around me I don't think I
would have gotten in that much trouble
just because like I those are the people
that I related to so have a friend back
at home we so we used to go to this
place I think she's in jail now cuz she
was like selling weed when it was
illegal but she had a shit-ton she like
a sativa [ __ ] yeah that's like one
sativa wasn't even that big like yeah it
just started popping so she
like growing in that [ __ ] huh all in her
backyard and a Muslim
her name was mama Wendy's what we called
it so she had this uh house is in
Sacramento when you go down this road
called a Bradshaw it's just a bunch of
like farmland yeah then there's like
random houses so she had one of those
homes oh just a lot of land yeah so she
was one of those ladies that would allow
young kids to come through and just
partying oh that's dope right so people
just be doing drugs and drinking a [ __ ]
and like I didn't do drugs or anything
else like that but because my friends
would go there so I would be kicking it
with them and every [ __ ] time without
[ __ ] failed there would be a fight
there every [ __ ] they're gonna
[ __ ] ruin the spot yeah so I'm there
and it would always be on some [ __ ] like
where because we knew mama Wendy yeah
well so mama Wendy we always wanted to
be you know how like those are very
respectful towards like people they
really like yeah so for we would be
there and then there'd be some random
people trying to roll up come through
but you know drinks aren't free you
don't know who the [ __ ] you are
ya know could be thirty just like
crashing the party trying to crash the
party so without [ __ ] fail somebody
would bring somebody to them yeah and
next thing you know like let's go
actually [ __ ] man and I'm a big guy yeah
so I'm like okay let's do this and then
we all have to get into a fight it's
just like [ __ ] man
so I stopped one in that place but she
she's in jail on her computer here damn
yeah man I don't know so sometimes I
feel like when I think back it's like
wow what a different life yeah I have
friends still in it they want to go out
have dinner but they're all grown now
but some of the guys they're still doing
time and I am one of my buddies this was
a stupidest thing stupidest thing too
this was after the club everyone was
kind of drunk sobering up and we were
eating soondubu in k-town yeah
this guy looks had him eat weird to get
into a yelling match the other guy
didn't want to back down he pulls out a
knife and he starts stabbing him in his
throat hmm cameras everywhere what the
[ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy I [ __ ] ran out
of there I was like you guys are [ __ ]
nuts man
yeah and then the last straw for me was
we were we were going into a parking lot
after the club and then a well-known do
we were going into a part well first we
went we're gonna go to a restaurant and
one of the girls doesn't like this other
girl so they got in a fistfight in the
security kicked us out so we went to
another restaurant but in between that
someone inside of there saw was a rival
to one of the guys there so they they
called his buddies yeah and as we were
driving out to the next restaurant which
was across the street
once we parked we got out of the car we
got shot at No and I was like dude I
just want to have dinner with my friends
yeah [ __ ] yeah it gets to that point too
and when I was when I was going to
church
I saw a member I wanted to be a youth
minister yeah so it got to that point to
even were like I don't even really kick
it with these people anymore yeah but
when you see them out of know what
you're gonna say what's up yeah right
but just even that small affiliation you
can get into trouble just being around
these people because they'll stupid [ __ ]
that they do and it's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing so I should you not so I
was taking out my church kids to go
bowling right I'm a [ __ ] youth
minister in training yeah and so I'm
taking these kids out to go bowling I
see one of my homies from back in the
day I'm like eight kids keep bowling
whatever there's a couple of chaperones
there I go out I go I'm like what's up
do as I say what's up to him right
[ __ ] dudes roll up and they just
start [ __ ] squabble it right there
and I'm like yo what the [ __ ] is going
on and so people are getting jumped yeah
and this this isn't a really great
bowling alley area but it was during the
time of day where it was Pope nothing
was supposed to happen yeah and it's the
cheapest spot not sure yeah a lot of
money so these dudes just start
squabbling [ __ ] cops come I get
tackled I'm not even your guilty by
association
you're there they don't know who started
what yeah they just got to grab you and
assess the situation and I'm freaking
the [ __ ] out because number one I'm
thinking somebody's gonna get shot
somebody's gonna get stabbed yeah I'm a
[ __ ] youth minister at this point and
I'm freaking out I get tackled and cops
are so [ __ ] mean by the way obviously
it's a very bad situation
[ __ ]
but yeah we said but I'm cool because
like the other dudes like you know they
put you to the back of the car we're all
sitting down we're cuffed you know and
real quick and these guys are like you
know he
not even a part of this like he's about
like a youth minister my kids are inside
yeah and so all the guys like he's not a
part of us like he's just like sitting
I'm like my kids are inside like I'm a
chaperone youth minister yeah so they
[ __ ] let me go they uncuffed me and I
was like [ __ ] is going on
that [ __ ] was so weird I was like dude
even if I talk to one of them this
happens and that's what I think but you
just have to be around a good group of
people yeah they don't they don't give a
[ __ ] yeah people don't care yeah but
when you I don't know when you grow up
with them I think like for those that
are listening and you have friends like
that and you're kind of stuck and you
don't know where to go I remember
feeling more comfortable with them than
with like people that are like old Navy
people just like regular people
like when I when I started hanging out
with regular people
I felt I actually felt intimidated oh
really
not like scared of them of course it's
not it's a different it's like it's like
not fitting in you know like when you're
so used to a certain kind of world and
like what's cool to them mmm you know
and then when you start going to college
and you start hanging out with like
normal people right like um I feel like
I'm not good enough or it's weird dude
it's like it's almost like you're poor
and you walk into a rich restaurant you
feel like you feel out of place you know
that that's what it felt like for me
when I went to UCR oh really when I want
you to get us [ __ ] exactly but that's
the crazy thing yeah so like just that
university life because a lot of like
you see our students at that time it was
a bunch of kids who couldn't get into
UCLA and they would you see are now mind
you I'm not sure if like academia is in
it's something that they care about a
lot but there were a lot of people who
grew up with money that went to UCI yeah
I don't know what that life is like at
all so I had the hardest trouble like
relating to a lot of people so the
people that I can relate to actually he
just texted me today like for example
there's a friend named Tony Tony group
and Gardena like you did oh yeah I could
relate to Tony yeah Tony's kind of a
dweeby dude right so Tony he was like a
magnet kid yeah he was one of those like
hyper intelligent magnet kids he did the
whole like when we graduated college
he's so [ __ ] smart he got this s2k
and he wanted to figure out how to
I think he turned the it was an
automatic at the time and he turned into
a manual cart and he just figured out
without looking up at anything oh she
could dissemble some [ __ ] and rebuild
her [ __ ] smartest [ __ ] that's crazy
but because even though he's like highly
intelligent kind of a dweeb shout out to
you Tony sorry your dweeb but he because
he grew up in a very similar type of
like lifestyle and area yeah I can
relate to him way more we could talk
about things I could like just just two
people being poor together can relate
way more than somebody else who grew up
it had more than me exactly yeah and I
think beyond race how you grew up like
like the type of culture like not even
just like ethnic culture but like a lot
of culture is like because it's created
because of like how much money you make
yeah you know like like service industry
families like you know I mean blue
collared or whatever that's why I think
I connect way more with people that that
used to be broken and they made
something of themself versus someone
that was born and raised in that rich
crowd cuz like there's a ton of agents
that are like rich or upper-middle class
and you know I do have some friends that
are like that but I could never get too
close because we can't just see eye to
eye sometimes it's just different yeah
their world how they solve problems it's
different than yeah like how they tackle
things it's way different it's dink
their idea of loyalty I mean their idea
of like what your commitment to
friendship is and all that it's they
don't see eye to eye
like I mean we don't see eye to eye they
do in their world you know so and I
think that's what prevents us too from
being super close and there might be
some diamonds in the rough and I think
it's the same for them too but for me
like I'm just more comfortable around
people that's like lower middle class or
they grew up that way and they're not
anymore because I don't link I don't I
don't connect with people that stay that
way yeah I just I it's like but if you
if you were that or you grew up that way
and you went to college or you you you
elevated in life somehow
like for example Jess my girlfriend
right like she
she used to tell me that the guys that
she dated never wanted to listen to her
past and they they made her feel like
she was tainted that she wasn't this
like pure person with a with a normal
nuclear family yeah like they want to
hear about her broken home family and
all that [ __ ] and for me I feel closer
to her because of that [ __ ] cuz I feel
lighter yeah because we relate to that
and I'm all all [ __ ] yeah you had to
struggle like that to like that brings
me closer to you versus like I don't if
this girl's hell is sheltered and she's
never been through anything close to
what I've been through and then she
might take [ __ ] for granted then I'm
like I don't know I don't know I can't
connect with her the way that I could
connect with this girl you know what I
mean can I tell you guys something can I
tell you what this genius brain podcast
is brought to you by I think it's
Skillshare
multiple notes for no damn reason so if
you guys don't know what Skillshare is
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes in design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career so basically what I'm saying is
that if you have a new passion out there
you have a side hustle that you want to
start or begin this is a great way to go
at it Skillshare basically gives you
that knowledge at your [ __ ]
finger tips my friends so for me the
classes that I'm taking right now
specifically have to do with photography
because photography is something that I
like to do on the side and because I did
it through an apprenticeship back in the
day there's a lot of I guess you could
say like fundamental basics that I don't
know and going through these courses
helped me out and it kind of adheres to
the way that I like to learn which is on
my own time so a lot of the times when
you go through traditional courses or
classes sometimes it's a little derived
and it doesn't teach you the things that
you want to learn what with skill sure
it has like your own library and you
could you know fast forward or rewind or
learn however the hell you want so
that's why I [ __ ] with Skillshare a lot
so remember people join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners you get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right skills
shares
for ingenious brain listeners two months
of unlimited access to over 25,000
classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash brain again go to
Skillshare comm slash brain to start
your two months now that is Skillshare
dot-com slash brain when you guys are on
there let me know the courses that
you're taking if you like it let me know
in the comments below because you know
what I [ __ ] with it I'm using it and
trust me people my photo skills is
getting up there skill Shey dude even
something small like going to a
restaurant and watching some of these
people that I met in college and how
they treat people as people in the
service and just yeah was a big factor
for ya because I knew a lot of people
that were in the service industry my
parents on their own business and I we
do customer service in customer
relations so when I like something small
like for example let's say I got a dish
and some people might think this is you
know me just not speaking up about stuff
but how I see it how I see a lot of
things when I go into a restaurant is I
see small business owner trying to pay
their rent yes yeah you go well okay I'm
not in an American restaurant I'm in a
immigrant own restaurant in their world
this is their standard like I know what
their standards are and I'm not gonna be
able to address this with them like you
you could assess the situation
yeah for example if you got a [ __ ] I
don't know like like cilantro when you
ask for no cilantro or whatever and it
comes out you're like [ __ ] I
said no cilantro
you could ask him but he might argue
with you but you gotta be okay with that
yeah I know because it's like time and
place like where are you at yeah
if you because I would be pissed if that
should happen at an American restaurant
yeah I think you could understand
English [ __ ] yeah like I
definitely have that that empathy
towards like smaller business people
yeah and even something small like going
out with a friend and they uh let's say
I got a dish and it came out like five
minutes later than theirs
yeah it doesn't bother me no no but I've
seen like friends who are like you I
can't believe your dish is coming out
way that I need let me talk to the
manager real quick and I'm like wow I
don't know if that's really worth it
here in this situation you know what I
mean what is that gonna do
I gonna fix it you're gonna get a
discount like what the [ __ ] yeah
and I don't know what it is maybe it's
like for them it's like a sense of
responsibility that they feel like they
need to fix that restaurant or whatever
it is yeah but for me I see it as you
know if I make this person let's say
like they even mess up one part of my
dish and I tell them to throw this out
and make another dish I'm like [ __ ]
that's money out of the pocket but I can
eat this and still enjoy it yeah so I
weigh out stuff like that but if
somebody grew up where they thought that
I don't want it's not like so much that
a silver spoon is in their mouth but if
they were told that the whole world
works this way and is supposed to work
for you only yeah they're not gonna have
that empathy and that's something I
think that we have being like number one
like people who just didn't have a lot
of money yeah we understand what that
struggle is liya and we understand that
that food something comes from somewhere
that's why sometimes I have issues with
the Yelp reviews like they they rate
these restaurants that are family-owned
businesses right and it let's say like
they didn't like their food that they
thought it was okay right but for them
they write a review thinking like oh
this is just a hobby of mine and I want
to review restaurants but they're also
not thinking is like when you gave that
restaurant a two-star right to start
because you thought that it wasn't as
good as a different tie restaurant and
you brought therefore to a three-star
that can't be potentially hundreds of
customers that you're preventing from
going to that restaurant exactly yes
it's a pretty big [ __ ] deal people
don't see it like that so for me when I
write these yelp reviews and I still do
every now and then I don't use my name
but I either give somebody a four and a
five or if it's if you get a one it's
because you might hate you like you know
to hail like your food was bad you
called me a [ __ ]
it was really bad yeah but other than
that I'm like if it's if it was average
food just leave it alone leave the
restaurant alone you know I could I
think I've only written three one-star
reviews in my whole lifetime yeah and I
can remember every single one one was
that [ __ ] up restaurant that closed
down remember those mean ladies all the
Korean really family yeah and barbecue
family they were that so mean a family
my ass dude that was [ __ ] up they
closed down rightfully so right and we
tried to remember we tried to
accommodate to them yeah I was trying to
service them as [ __ ] and then they were
just insulting yeah like talking [ __ ] to
our face
laughing at us and Nelson [ __ ] the [ __ ]
dude that was one too
I caught a restaurant cheating cuz I was
a I was counting my macros so I had a
food scale with me yeah so I went to
this crab joint right and then um you
know I would weigh out my food and I'm
like oh [ __ ] like this crab leg is like
half the I'm supposed to get a pound of
crab this one's only half a pound oh
[ __ ] right and I told him like hey you
know just to let you know I don't know
how you guys are measuring this but this
is half a pound of crab yeah they
immediately got defensive yeah they were
like no it's a pound your scale is
tricked you're it's wrong and I'm all
like I'm like hey I'm still gonna pay
the same amount I'm just letting you
know that this is half a pound and it
says here I'm showing you on the scale
they're like no you're trying to trick
me with that scale and I'm like all
right dude
yeah I'm like I'm not even okay [ __ ] you
you know that's all I said I was like
[ __ ] it dude I'm just gonna write a
review and then I weighed out all the
seafood it was all scam dude yeah and I
was like why why are you such a piece of
[ __ ] like why ya cheat your customers
yeah and then get defensive
cuz what what you know how you could
have remedied it he could have been like
oh [ __ ] really go back fill it up and
guess what you could have cheated maybe
your other customers yeah maybe not me
like you know fix the problem but like I
don't know he took it really offensive
and I was I was like I'm not even trying
to like fight dude I'm just gonna pay
the whole bill it's what did you know
like you guys mismeasured this [ __ ] yeah
yeah and then another one um [ __ ] what
was the other one
ah [ __ ] I guess I didn't remember all
three yeah yeah but you know like I
could I could if it didn't leave a big
impression
I don't care yeah it's not a big deal
yeah you know like to some of these
Yelpers credits like when they do bring
up big problems it does help you know
but I just wish sometimes it's like you
should have addressed it to the
restaurant instead of writing it on the
Yelp and they can't even help fix the
problem that you had yeah all you had to
do was say excuse me like this is this
how it normally is what blah blah blah
and if they can't remedy it then maybe
you could talk about that during your
yelp review yeah but the problem is is
and people don't give an opportunity to
fix a problem yes restaurants aren't
perfect people aren't perfect you're not
perfect in an author if and if the food
was just disgusting yeah yeah you have I
feel like you write it write it you know
like I don't know yeah I do think that
restaurant culture because we're a
melting pot is very different in America
you know and you can't apply like I
always think if you especially if you go
to ethnic place you cannot apply
you can't expect American culture in
that restaurant I'm looking at it like
I'm going inside like the [ __ ] what do
you call it like a like a emissary or
like oh yeah you know like a ambassador
look at like a oh yeah it's like I feel
like is that as I opened the door I'm
stepping foot into that country yeah and
whatever their rules go they they go
there yeah cuz it's like like I even
read reviews like I'm just bringing back
to Thai restaurants or something and
review for this place yeah but somebody
wrote yeah I ordered their papaya salad
and it was completely inedible it was
way too hot I'm like [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] Thai food [ __ ] is my
Chili's it's supposed to [ __ ] burn
your spirit that's what that's food is
for you can't tell somebody how spicy
Thai food should be when you're not of
that culture that's what that food is
everybody knows [ __ ] they call them
[ __ ] Satan dick peppers like what did
you would do because they think their
opinion is the right one yeah cuz uh I
remember I was looking at one of these
sushi restaurants I think it was Nozawa
Zoar basically it was it was all [ __ ] t
yeah right and then in one of the
reviews they're like what kind of sushi
restaurant doesn't have California rolls
what the [ __ ] that's a and I'm like are
you [ __ ] dumb yeah you go to Japan
and order a California roll they're
gonna be like what's that
yeah what the [ __ ] that is like I even
read this play so this is joint out in
k-town called booze Philly cheesesteak
and it says by this Korean American guy
who started up a Philly cheesesteak
joint because his dad wanted
cheesesteaks because he's from Philly
but nobody had a good cheesesteak here
and that's how a lot of these
restaurants pop up and a grip they
create stuff that they
can't have that they want yeah and so
they made a dope cheese stick and this
lady wrote this review and she was like
I can't believe people eat at this place
it's just all cheese and meat and this
grease I it's disgusting and I'm like
[ __ ] that's a cheese steak [ __ ] that's
exactly what a Philly cheesesteak is
that's what people like about it cheap
Cheez Whiz ya know I say what did you
what the [ __ ] did you expect that's what
it's not for you yeah it's not for you
yes what it's not for you that's it
that's so funny but you can't complain
see I think this is the thing when it
comes to music right like we kind of
have this we're like you'll have I don't
know like you'll have like college age
boys complaining about Justin Bieber or
like yeah like or like teeny bopper
music and it's like it's not for you
[ __ ] what are you why
complaining like this is romantic music
for the ladies or whatever yeah but we
don't have that for food yeah cuz food
we have this culture of we make it the
way you like it that's the American
restaurant culture right like customers
king customer's always right service is
good like it's all about Oh like it's
all about customization yeah hold the
pickles I want this I want that add more
Mayo that's the way I like my murder
right and and I think that i call it
holly mentality it's it's like they
forget that outside of that there's a
whole lot more going on you know a lot
of people who go to japan they compare
it like japanese service to american
service they go when I go to Japan
they're super polite things are done
this way and we get our food like that I
was like well also in Japan too they had
that that omakase a style stuff it's
like you don't customize [ __ ] that's why
you get it yes there's a system set
versus yeah you [ __ ] up the system it
makes things slow
yeah so people don't understand that too
and then we also talk about stuff like
[ __ ] well in Japanese they make a
living wage dah dah dah dah and I'm like
well that's true too
but did you see the type of service that
they give so there's there's a balance
to that alright so if you like if you
want to work a part-time job like a
dumbass then you're gonna get a
dumbasses wage yeah but I'm pretty sure
you're not having Japanese service
attention
and doing the amount of responsibilities
that they have so they get paid
according to their work ethic and they
work hard damn dude they're doing the
job of three people yeah they did
it's sad to me I'm like I don't want to
work like that did you eat horse with us
in Japan nope
yeah so we were at yep so it was me I
think I was like me Casey and I can't I
think was ant too so we went to this
barbecue Japanese barbecue joint and
when we walked in I don't realize it was
horse until I looked at the diagrams I
don't like you know that [ __ ] cow
looks really skinny oh [ __ ] this is a
horse restaurant you guys wanted
Japanese barbecue yeah and so first of
all [ __ ] delicious yeah horse meat is
[ __ ] good dude I need to be eating
horse all the time [ __ ] those animals so
protection pop dude so yo so we couldn't
speak Japanese and she couldn't speak
English but I'm talking about her
service was so on point every time she
spoke she can't say sorry because she
couldn't speak English yeah in Japan you
don't have to apologize for anything yet
if anything I should know how to speak
Japanese yeah but she was just like
sorry sorry sorry
I thought her neck was gonna [ __ ]
hell on sunny sunny sunny Saudi so we're
just doing the Google Translate and yeah
asking for what we wanted but I I was
kind of shocked I was like damn dude
even when we're in their country
speaking a foreign language she's
apologizing for not knowing how to speak
my language yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
dude it's just um there's a difference
in culture right like I think in America
we feel that everybody should assimilate
to us yeah because technically what
makes you an American is a state of mind
not your race hmm so it's it's like if
you believe in the freedoms you know
capitalism and and and those at least
those rules I think I think that's what
technically is an American right and
then so like when you come here that's
why I think a lot of people are like oh
you should be more American speak more
English do this and and there's a fine
line because it's like well chewy
whitewash or should we hold on to some
culture yeah and and that's where the
debate is right but then I think there's
so many immigrants coming in we it's
like we want them to become American
but for Japan and it's in it's in it's a
world where everyone caters to us but in
Japan it's you you know you're Japanese
right mmm there's no like in people
foreigners that are coming you know
they're coming to visit they're not
coming to stay
so what we're mainly taught is like give
the best be the best host you can be mmm
so it's it's you know I think there's a
lot of like I bet like if you lived in a
tourist world where if Americans felt
like all these foreigners that are
coming are just coming to visit and
enjoy the culture but not staying
they might it might change oh yeah yeah
it might be like yeah come on in spend
your money have fun okay bye yeah I hope
you had a great time here yeah you know
cuz Japan and I think Iceland are like
the two last ethno you know non-diverse
country ever mmm they're like 90 percent
Japanese or one race yeah yeah so you
know and then it's a service it's like a
what do you call it like like it's a
people first kind of culture right so
it's like you you think of others first
that's how you become a better human
being not yourself I think out here it's
all about it's it's a little more
selfish compared to that it's all about
independent thinking what are my rights
my thoughts yeah you cultivate my
freedom you know it's all my thoughts
hmm but out there it's smart it's more
like oh we have a guest how can I make
it the most comfortable as possible yeah
yeah and then she's like [ __ ] man I took
English classes I know I could have done
better you know cuz you because you were
telling me to when you were in Japan
with Jess Jess felt really weird wearing
the kimono yeah but it was during it was
the area where everybody was wearing
that [ __ ] and that was like something
that people want tourists to wear yeah
she didn't want to take the pictures cuz
she felt weird as a white woman like
wearing cultural things you know because
I think just it's hella sensitive in
America right like I like I don't know
like she's like [ __ ] her other agents
gonna feel about it I feel comfortable
and I'm like look
you're [ __ ] beautiful wearing that
thing my mom is the one that wants to
put you in that outfit yeah because my
mom never had a daughter she always
wanted a daughter and she's got two boys
yeah she got two boys and in the reason
why she wanted to put Jess in a kimono
is because it's like a mother-daughter
thing that you do when a when a girl's a
woman so it's like a Japanese cancion
era right when a woman I think it's in
her 20s or something yeah but when she
becomes a certain age the cut of the
kimono changes Oh
and so the mom and the daughter go
together and back in the day was like
the mom would like buy this outfit for
her and it was like a big thing like
you're becoming a woman now you know so
like and and now the way that they do it
in Japan is like at that age like girls
they wear that kimono now you could wear
the kimono with a long sleeve or
whatever and then you take pictures and
then like you kind of memorize that
moment so she wanted to do that with
Jess and in souls like telling Jess this
is a special thing for her you know and
it's not it's nothing to worry about and
if you walk around on the streets like
Japanese people love it when you
celebrate their culture they don't go
like man why the [ __ ] are you making a
mockery of us yeah like come along
everybody come over we're [ __ ] we're
close drink drinks and eat our food and
it's not like jess is wearing the kimono
in Japan talking to Japanese people
about what it should mean to them know
it's theirs it has a very different
narrative you know it's not hurt wearing
it to tell people like oh I'm Japanese
and I'm gonna teach you about Japanese
culture it's like no this is a tourist
thing to do and they want you to
experience yeah this part of Japan and I
don't but I don't blame her for her like
insecurities for I think American media
definitely American yeah and then they
make white people afraid to enjoy
culture sometimes you know and I'm like
damn that sucks man like that girl with
the the Chinese dress when she was on
Twitter yeah dude she look so pretty in
that dress and a [ __ ] dumbass Asian
kid was like that you [ __ ] culture is
not your costume you [ __ ] nerd shut
the [ __ ] up dude shut I know I hate
fools like that and it's so stupid too
because like I mean
they even went back into his tweets and
he was dropping n bombs like a
[ __ ] so who the [ __ ] are you you
piece of trash and then on top of that
yo did you hear like Chinese press
they're like what's the problem right
like what's the [ __ ] problem I don't
get it and that's the kind of [ __ ] that
makes Asian Americans look stupid yeah
when stupid [ __ ] like that are out
there like they're [ __ ] dumb as hell
and then they're like trying to champion
some type of like message yeah there was
this one Filipino girl right like
Ubisoft or whatever they were coming out
with this game and there was this white
guy doing taiko drums right but the
funny thing is so this [ __ ] of course
was mad she was like why couldn't they
find a Japanese like authentic guy doing
taiko drums right this [ __ ] is so
stupid this white guy is a actual
musician in Japan who studied this for
like 30 years yeah and he celebrated in
Japan because like he's a hot guy to do
he's not good yeah yeah and then and
then she's like oh my god I couldn't
believe they couldn't find a Japanese
person to do that I'm like Japanese
people don't even [ __ ] care yeah I
don't care look to me I'm like who cares
yeah that's not that's not the problem
the problem is when you have it when you
have a Japanese story and then like you
have to like put a white guy in it
and--but your Filipino [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] you know she hook that's so [ __ ]
water right but I mean there are there
are white washing of things yeah it
happens so these idiots don't know what
to look for
yeah but like don't point the finger at
the people that are on our side and you
know what's kind of crazy you know
especially with that Chinese dressing
right like I've seen that dress be worn
by plenty of people in my high school
dude black people have Mexicans whatever
yo I don't know how many [ __ ] black
girls you know named China but I know a
lot of black girls in China or Asia yeah
like their name that's like a common
black it'll make like Asia yeah
like what the [ __ ] like you know so it
never really bothered me and there was a
hot minute in the 2000s where everybody
every every chick was putting chopsticks
in their hair yeah that [ __ ] was huge
didn't bother me didn't even think I'm
like okay I don't know why you eat your
food with that and put in your hair but
is what it is yeah but it never really
bothered me and I you know I understand
you know people not wanting somebody
that takes something from the culture
and take credit from it like I kind of
get it I do yeah but I also see it as
we're [ __ ] America dude like world's
a melting pot it's a melting pot like a
[ __ ] yeah isn't out of
everywhere that is something that is
supposed to happen in this world don't
you think it would happen here right
like we're all like a mix of all these
different cultures and we're picking and
choosing from from each other all the
[ __ ] time yeah I only care if if
they're authentically celebrating [ __ ]
yeah or they're just being an idiot in
mimicking like so for example like like
the like the taiko drum guy or or you
know the I've ar-rahman or well yeah I
Ivan yeah Ivan ramen or like people that
even if they fetishize Asian [ __ ] if
they did the work and they studied it
for 40 years and they loved it to death
there is that freedom too I think so
dude I know like who the [ __ ] cares let
him do it
Ivan Orkin that [ __ ] he married
a Japanese woman opened up a popular
Japanese restaurant in Japan and he
speaks Japanese yeah that's [ __ ]
Japanese kids at the [ __ ] do you want
from him dude yeah
like what else do you want from this guy
now I don't care if because it's it
takes people like that to bridge the
culture together yeah you know and it's
also funny too because I remember
watching his stuff on an unmet flix and
then in the docu-series like his final
statement he goes he goes a lot of
people are telling me that you know I
hear some stuff where they might say
like this isn't authentic ramen he goes
well once you open up a [ __ ]
restaurant in Japan he goes then you
come talk to me yeah thanks it's true
though like well how are you an
authority about a food that you've never
made creative apprenticed under or
anything but I've done the work and I'm
creating this dish out of respect and
then now you're telling me just because
you're Asian that you know what a better
a bowl of ramen is because of the color
of your skin yeah that doesn't make
sense to me yeah you know I see this
dude he did the work he did the
apprenticeship ASIS to think that
someone that isn't of that culture can
make it good
oh yeah not a percent even when that
whole thing happened right yeah I who
did the whole
Oh funny people were so mad and you know
I got a little bit of flack because I
defended the guy because if let's say
that would do wasn't white right yeah it
was a Vietnamese guys everybody would
been like yeah that's how you really eat
Vietnamese food yes how you supposed to
do his son but but all they saw was the
color of his skin and they go he can't
say that [ __ ] I'm like but it's not like
he was off like even when I eat a bowl
of pho I don't put like a bunch of
[ __ ] hoisin and sriracha in the
showers I taste that [ __ ] for ya I taste
the broth first see that's how I was
told to do it anyway so it's like oh
well I relate you guys I [ __ ] with this
guy like you know what's up I think I
think what people don't want is people
don't know anything about Vietnamese
people already right so they don't want
the white guy to speak for them yeah
because there's plenty of Vietnamese
Americans I get that but they people
also have to understand that it takes
these brave white people to first care
about it to talk to their other white
people yeah and then the more people get
into it they'll get into the true [ __ ]
yeah like that's what happened to sushi
oh yeah everybody in the 80s was like
ooh sushi raw fish gross yeah now it's
like the most [ __ ] expensive thing
now it's like high society food you know
all the richest and famous white people
want to [ __ ] eat it but it wasn't
always like that right but it's like you
got to understand the evolution of how
things get to where they are you can't
you can't you can't be like no no no no
like we you know it has to be us all the
time there's just also this kind of like
this level of [ __ ] snobbery with food
sometimes too you know
like you know people cuz you know we eat
at a lot of like dope restaurant
specifically specifically because we
live in LA yeah but that doesn't mean
I'm not gonna have a McDonald's soft
serve you know you know right people
talk about food that they've eaten their
whole lives like it's trash now because
now they're elevated in their food like
yo chill like calm the [ __ ] down
like I'll make like an edge Lord
underground [ __ ] yeah like I'm
like I'll cook like add oatmeal right
but then I guarantee you when you guys
eat the food that I mean I'm eating a
bowl of kimchi meat you know yeah so I
you know there's their snobbery to -
it's like you like what you like man
like I love a good fast-food taco
sometimes yeah like it's like do you
only eat at [ __ ] fancy restaurants
because if you do then you don't really
know food do perception is so [ __ ]
skewed because you know when we went to
Vegas I we ate at that Gordon Ramsay
burger joint and that [ __ ] was not
[ __ ] good it's even in the Yelp
reviews right but all they saw in that
video was me making fun of this burger
and i'ma it's a comedians channel too by
the way
and I didn't like the burger really oh
what the [ __ ] do you know about food did
you [ __ ] eat the burger [ __ ] did you
[ __ ] eat the burger like if you didn't
eat the burger then you don't have a say
in this [ __ ] I'm just telling you what I
feel about it
you know what I mean I don't believe in
Michelin star ratings anymore I ate at
three restaurants with over two-star one
was an actual three-star Michelin rating
all of them suck dick I went to one in
France no I went to two in France it was
the second one wasn't so bad I went to
joelrose Shan in Vegas it wasn't good no
I I paid almost $300 I swear to you I
try to stay optimistic because of how
much I paid I was like the bread is
awesome the waters delicious I got my
main entree which was salted salted beef
cheeks at the end of all this [ __ ] I was
like just lying to myself because of how
much I paid so you're right I was close
to $300 so I'm saying perception is true
yeah what the way the a call comes out
but when I look back the more I started
to hate what I what I was like thinking
because I'm like no it didn't taste good
why did I why did I say that it's cuz I
paid a lot of money man people like I
don't know if people could even wrap
their head around this and I think uh
and what I mean by people I'm talking
about people who are food snobs I feel
like these foods knots can't even wrap
their head around this like I say like
have you had a sturgeon caviar before I
think of oh [ __ ] amazing
I'm like really out of all the things
that you've eaten this this this this
fish now I've had sturgeon caviar right
yeah it's good it's a salty fish ball
yeah and you're like um one of the best
things I've ever eaten
really bro yeah if you never saw that on
Gordon
Ramzi talking about it or some high chef
and you just saw this this plate of
black balls and you ate that [ __ ] you
would you eat that and be like wow this
is [ __ ] crazy I bet you it's one of
those things like not though you got a
be a quiet it's got it you got to build
it right I understand what it's good
like I get taste good but I guarantee
you objectively speaking this salty ball
of salt water that you're eating has not
is not the best thing you've ever eaten
even truffle the concept of truffle
right it's because it's an expensive
thing you see it on every [ __ ]
cooking show right yeah but people
anything with truffle and they're like
that truffle oil though what what about
it it's just rough yeah it's good but is
it the most amazing that you know oh
yeah without I don't like I mean to me
truffles meant to be subtle yeah it's
not meant to be like in like so much you
know some people like a lot of truffle
but like not me like it's just it's just
some weird and it's okay like if you
have truffle too and you say I don't
like it it's okay nothing's wrong with
your taste buds yeah just don't like you
don't [ __ ] with it that's all that it is
that's very true yeah like when I say
like oh you don't like this you're tres
it's a joke like I don't actually think
that ours is trash but people take it
too seriously now like oh my god you
don't you don't like [ __ ] a sushi you
don't like raw fish you're [ __ ] your
palates not elevated or they just don't
like ya or they just don't like it
yeah is what it is and a lot of people
can't break down why something is good
yeah because I feel like the better you
are as an artist you can break down the
reasons for why you like this sensation
cuz it's all a sensation right it's like
oh I like the texture yeah oh I like
this kind of taste like I like crunchy
textures or whatever it is right and a
lot of food snobs have you noticed they
don't cook yeah they don't [ __ ] cook
dude they just go around eating [ __ ]
talking but they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about to me they
remind me of those uh fake art snobs
that walk around yeah very art museums
and talk about the artists motivation
and this and that and I'm just like but
you [ __ ] don't even paint
either yo if there's a food stop the
thing I want to do too is like we got to
start that
[ __ ] food up like a haha let's do it
do you know what my god I want to start
this [ __ ] food app it's like Yelp
well you could rate these restaurants or
businesses but there's open
communication for the users to talk [ __ ]
to each other - yes and they get to up
and down vote whatever the [ __ ] they say
I think it's good there has to be that
type of communication because it's not
fair that the restaurant just sits there
and gets beat down yeah it's it's really
not yeah it's not fair people she may be
able to open communicate cuz even like
the YouTube comments are [ __ ] cancer
but I wouldn't take it away because you
learn a lot actually yeah yeah you do
there there needs to be that open type
of communication - and I feel like - if
your and I have this I want to put this
thing like if if you're using the app
and you have over a thousand reviews on
it you're just labeled as a loser the
[ __ ] loser tag that's what you get do
you that's what you gotta do it man I
really do want that man I want to do it
I'd [ __ ] promote the [ __ ] out of it
cuz I want I want I want to get
recommend to a place because it tastes
good yeah that's all I [ __ ] care
about there should be a separate
separate we're thinking about like
having a separate review rating - so
it's not like this cumulative like three
or four star school it's like it's her
thing ambience for place food serving
like service service like do they talk
to you whatever cuz I don't give a [ __ ]
about food service yeah so as long as
they're not mean yeah so it's about like
you being able to judge a place for the
rating that you care about the most
yeah so I was like I care about this
place because the [ __ ] food is
amazing the service is trash but I don't
really give a [ __ ] I just want to eat
that food yeah and a lot of these
restaurants do have that quality where
surface is not on point like
specifically mom-and-pop stores a lot of
Chinese restaurants yeah because it's
just service is different in their
culture yeah which to me I got used to
because I grew up in a Chinese
neighborhood yeah so it's just different
and people writing reviews - they go oh
I would give it like a three point eight
and at three point five maybe but I gave
it a 3 instead of this well why don't we
do it separately where it's you give
them a five for the food you give them a
three for the service and the whatever
the the one for the cleanliness cuz it's
a Chinese restaurant
we could decide whether they want to go
to it or not yeah I think anyways oh
yeah I love Chinese food man it's so
good
see there I think I think they cut to
the chase they're like does it taste
good
yes let's do it move on yeah does it
look good [ __ ] no but it tastes huh
you want some but ankle soup yeah I know
that cow head the eyeball is looking at
you but that's good luck oh [ __ ] it's an
hour in alright there we go guys well
that [ __ ] concludes another episode
of the genius brain podcast remember
everybody if you guys want to catch us
Thursday and Sunday's are the upload
days you can catch us on cast box iTunes
stitcher a [ __ ] Spotify wherever you
want remember we're a podcast just about
conversation just having fun so take us
along with your days Joe will be on here
as soon as possible every Thursday so
it's gonna be me and Joe section on
Thursdays and so leave a comment down
below on anything you guys want us to
talk about because we read all the
comments and we go based off of what is
highly requested yeah the podcast will
be moving to a different room soon so
it's probably gonna look a little
different but other than that man thank
you for your support we've been getting
sponsors now so trying to make sure that
I'm gonna suck dick for a living thank
you very much for that appreciate it you
guys care so total amount of [ __ ]
peace